So what are your thoughts and experience with chronicle treatments using DMSO?
And this was an article that they linked to with DMSO in cancer.
So what's the benefit of DMSO with cancer? So DMSO, first of all, is a great
anti-inflammatory, topical anti-inflammatory. That's how it was first really used
medicineally as an anti-inflammatory. So you put some liquid DMSO, it's like water,
thymethyl sulfoxide, and you put it on your knee, that's injured, and it can decrease the
inflammation of your knee quite quickly. The positive of DMSO is that it is absorbed like
instantaneously through the skin, and it goes right into the cell membranes and it can go deep.
The negative is because it absorbs so quickly, it pulls what you may have on the skin.
So let's say if you have some lotion with parabens and other toxins on your skin and you put
DMSO over it, you're going to be pulling that stuff right into your tissues, which that could be a
bad thing. So if you have toxins on your skin, and you use DMSO, your pulling toxins right in, it is,
it just pulls with it, whatever's next to it. So that is the negative of DMSO
something you have to be careful of. So you want to wash your skin and have clean skin,
and make sure that it's not going to be a carrier and pull it into the tissue. We've used DMSO
for years and years, we have our own DMSO zinc spray that people have used topically over breast
cancer over or prostate over. So that is something to use. You could buy DMSO just on Amazon, it's very
inexpensive. People use it to pull other things like the zinc to it, like we did to pull things
through the tissue. You could have some a little bit of curcumin cream on your breast, let's say,
and you put DMSO over it. We've used DMSO as an ointment mixture with a curcumin cream, it'll pull
the curcumin into the tissue. So there's pros to it. There's, if you looked at this article, there's
other articles that have shown that DMSO can actually stimulate apoptosis, it can block certain
oncogene pathways. There's other positive cancer things with DMSO. But with anything like this,
there's also a flip side. We've had people use DMSO on their breast cancer and they
strongly felt that it made it much worse. So you just have to be careful with anything that you do
and to test it. So DMSO is not a nutritional supplement. Even though you can buy it over the
calder, it's thought to be generally safe. You could overuse it. DMSO also will give off a sulfur
group because that's one of the things. In it is sulfur. Now the danger of having excess sulfur
that can push the glutathione pathway. So there is some downsides with using DMSO with that. You could
increase glutathione production and for cancer patients, we've described in detail why that may not
be a good thing. So while people have used DMSO for cancer effectively, for inflammation effectively,
we've had just as many people that said that it made things worse. So you do have to be careful
with everything you do. This would be considered in my classification as a drug, not as a
nutritional supplement. Whereas if you took a donation or you took garlic,
yeah, I could have a downside if garlic can have a downside if you're taking a medical blood
that hurt. You could have too much blood that eat. But there really isn't a downside with garlic and
cancer. But there can be a downside with DMSO and cancer. So just be careful with using different
protocols. You have to make sure you test things and go slowly with it.